the following content is provided under  a Creative Commons license your support  will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to  offer high quality educational resources  for free  to make a donation or view additional  materials from hundreds of MIT courses  visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu  so we have X is going to be whatever  number the user types in Y is going to  be whatever number the user types in  first thing I'm going to check is if X  is equal to Y so if we type in X is zero  and Y is 5 0 is not equal to 5 so we're  not even going to consider what's in  this code block then we're going to  check the next one if if 0 is less than  5 and that's true so this is the very  first conditional that evaluates to true  so we're just going to print X is  smaller and I think that's what that's  what's being dragged down here awesome